h
herzlich willkommen zur mod vorstellung
wie eventuell schon in meinen augen seht
oder an meiner nase oder an
irgendwelchen anderen dingen an dem man
das beurteilen kann
ich bin krank mich hat es irgendwie
jetzt auch erwischt ich bin total
erkältet mir geht scheiße ich wollte
eigentlich erst gar nichts hochladen
aber dann dachte ich bekomme solle
kleine motta wieder ist er eigentlich
ganz ehrlich ich möchte mich noch schon
entschuldigen dass ich in diesem video
und auch in den nächsten vier fünf
videos wahrscheinlich immer noch so eine
heisere stimme haben werde und so weiter
und so fort
eventuell waren in letzter zeit einfach
ein bisschen zu oft unterwegs ich bin
dann auch letztes sphinx einfach so
krass an zu regnen auf ein und ich
glaube dann nur im hemd über die straße
und so was wir doch einfach dumm
jedenfalls habe ich mir dabei gedacht
kommen lukas jetzt zusammen wenn es
schon nicht in der uni gehst du hast du
wenigstens jemanden video und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ich stelle euch
heute die gruppe los mod vor das ist so
auch zu deutsch übersetzt wachsende
ärzte mehr oder weniger ich sehe ich so
fertig aus wenn ich mir das so angucke
wo ich sehe ich sehr richtig wenn ihr
nämlich in minecraft nicht bock habt
irgendwie immer in höhlen zu gehen um
irgendwelche ärzte zu kriegen oder 1000
jahre langen enger zugehen um glos
downloader so zu kriegen oder der
jahrelang obsidian abzubauen oder so
dann könnt ihr einfach diese global spot
in eurem minecraft version mit ford 1.7
punkten
und dann könnt ihr ärzte einfach anbauen
das geht wie folgt und zwar erstmal
inventar haben wir hierfür wieder ihr
seht es hier sind wieder eins von zwei
bäckern rüber switch dann habe ich ihr
grübel das in die ganze blöcke die
hinzugefügt werden dass und nicht so
viele rolle der nachbar bord wieder das
ist echt ich war weil das wie viel kann
der muss doch seine ganze wohnung
auseinandernehmen bezweifelt zwar dass
habe ich gehört hat aber versucht was
wert wir brauchen auf jeden fall erstmal
diese grundvoraussetzungen das alles
hinzukriegen dieser großer block den
sehen wir hier schon so wird der ganze
betrachtet dann kriegen wir ein großer
block ich will so blöd wie soll ich da
noch nicht gelegt so meine lieben
freunde da ist auch schon der große
block wie durch magie dorthin gekommen
wir müssen diese sachen so anordnen
einfach diamant goldbarren einfach diese
sachen die man teilweise hier raus
bekommt aus denen aus den aus denen aus
dem schilf teilen da dann eine erde die
qual so diesem fruchtbaren boden
darstellen soll
und dann haben wir noch knochen mehl und
zucker war und dann bekommen wir diese
sachen hier heraus also wir bekommen
dann erstmal diesen komischen blog den
wir hier unten sehen das ist ein ganz
normaler blog wenn ich den abbau hört
sich das an als würdig sandra borgmann
hin oder erde glaube ich sogar ja das
ist sogar das ist sonst wie als wenn ich
erde abbauen würde und da kann ich dann
diese teile drauf platzieren werde ich
mir beispielsweise hier so eine android
nehme kann ich das nicht darauf
platziert sondern muss das dann hier
darauf platzieren
das ganze funktioniert auch nicht mit
bauen will also wenn ich hier
beispielsweise mal bauen will nehme und
hier drauf geht es schon da tut sich nix
also das kann ich nicht irgendwie
beschleunigen oder sogar bei dieser
großen block bildet auf jeden fall schon
mal den die grundvoraussetzung dafür
dass das ganze läuft und dann muss man
natürlich auch erst mal am anfang eher
zu investieren also ich muss erst mal
wenn ich einen diamanten habe muss ich
den erst mal hier rein packen und los
dann hier das zuhause anordnen und die
steine damit ich überhaupt einen diamond
tore bekommen der ablauf danach wäre
dann einfach dass ich dann dieses dumme
ding hier auf dem grün bock drauf setzte
und das wird danach derzeit einfach hoch
wachsen dann würde ich quasi dieses
demand dienste abbauen und dann können
wir hier in die kiste schauen und zwar
muss ich dann das diamond tory so
anordnen zusammen die supporter den
ganzen tag alter muss es dann quasi
einfach im crafting fällt zusammen kreis
anordnung dann bekomme ich einen
diamanten wieder raus also am anfang ist
es extrem schwer und langwierig bis ich
überhaupt da mal resultat daraus bekomme
aber auf dauer habe ich dann halt eine
riesige fahne und kann es dann einfach
einmal abbauen übrigens es geht
natürlich auch alles mit der hand ich
bin im creative mutig vollidioten liegt
nur rät jetzt bitte einfach dass born to
bedside dass du diese aufgabe drin ist
ich dachte die welt fertig mit ihren
scheiß bauarbeiten da oder irgendwie so
aber anscheinend ja nicht jedenfalls
wenn ich jemanden game auf null gehe und
ihr seht ich bin im game nur kann ich
das ganze auch hier einfach wie sie mit
der hand abbauen dann bekomme ich die
teile und die muss sich dann einfach
quasi entweder an pflanzen als neue
sachen damit wieder neu wachsen oder
halt einfach im crafting table so
anordnen damit ich einen diamanten
rausbekommen
also es ist nicht sehr ertragreich am
anfang aber gegen ende hat man halt
richtig viel davon und es wächst halt
einfach nach sind quasi nachwachsender
erz genau das gleiche funktioniert dann
beispielsweise auch mit lapislazuli was
man dann so anordnet und mit redstone
dort allerdings der unterschied dass
beim lapislazuli brauche ich nur viermal
platz bekommt zu bekommen oder
beispielsweise auch nur einen das ist
unter anderen auch so hierbei eisen oder
bei den anderen sachen oder bei kloster
bei obsidian ist es allerdings noch mal
ein bisschen anders im obsidian ist es
nämlich so dass wenn ich so ein obsidian
ried daraus bekommen möchte muss das ob
sie die antworten dann bekomme ich in
obsidian rief also dass das ganze ein
bisschen anders ihr findet die crafting
rezepte und in der beschreibung verlinkt
dort ist einfach auch einen downloadlink
wieder zum forum da im forum könnt ihr
euch dann auch noch mal genau die
zusammenstellung der crafting sache
anschauen genaue bilder nochmal wie
lange die brauchen um zu wachsen und so
weiter und so fort halten auch so ein
paar zusatzinfos ist auf jeden fall in
der beschreibung verlinkt das war's dann
auch schon zu dieser modifikation dies
für alle leute geeignet die sich einfach
denken wow ich habe keinen bock in der
höhle zu gehen oder so die können sich
aber so eine riesige unterirdische
fahren davon anlegen dass die ganzen
sachen die man damit sich holen kann
wir haben hier die places sachen wir
unter allem ob kloster und wir haben
auch solche sachen wie einfach netter
quatsch obsidian oder auch so was wie
ton einfach und tier
da bin ich gar nicht mal so affinen wird
irgendwie firma das jetzt unterbrochen
soll verändert werden oder so
wahrscheinlicher für jedes emerald
einfach ganz normal smaragde diamant
redstone maxplatz solid gold eisen und
kohle also kannst damit quasi wirklich
alles an pflanzen was es irgendwie gibt
in micron das war es dann auch schon von
dieser mod vorstellung es tut mit leid
dass die ein bisschen kürzer geraten ist
dass meine stimme ist es die nachbarn
wieder angefangen zu bauen
zurzeit ist halt alles nicht so das
gelbe vom ei das wird sich aber
demnächst alles besser also danach man
kann ja nicht noch länger als zwei
wochen da irgendwie rum bohren oder so
ich mal meine erkältung wird auch bald
wieder weggeht und dann ist alles wieder
beim alten nivea berlin freundlich habe
nie wieder gesagt und hier haben eine
lieben freunde es war extra ich wollte
mir auf jeden fall
ich möchte mich bedanken falls sie immer
noch dran seid dass ihr euch das video
angeschaut habt trotz dessen der ganzen
umstände die hier gerade dieses video
eingeschickt haben und sonst würde ich
mich freuen wenn ihr das video mit einer
positiven bewertung bewertet und wir
sehen uns in einem nächsten video wieder
uns war morgen bei einer runde wer bin
ich da bin ich beim live zu gast aber
ich habe ihm gesagt ich nehme auch mit
auf dadurch auch ein video habe für euch
für morgen und so weiter und so fort und
blau und blaue jeans